he was vice president of kenya for years
now william ruto is its president but is
he up to the job and what's his plan to
tackle the country's many problems this
is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell on monday the head of kenya's
electoral commission declared deputy
president william ruto winner nearly a
week after the presidential vote it was
a narrow victory with official results
showing ruto gained just over half of
the votes at 50.5 percent while raila
odinga received 48.8
but just before the results were
announced four election commissioners
cast doubt on the results while odinga's
agent also disputed them alleging
irregularities odinga is a former prime
minister and this was his fifth attempt
at running for president
he received the endorsement of his
longtime rival president uhuru kenyatta
but results show ruto one in mount kenya
president kenyatta's stronghold before
we go to our guests here is hari mutasa
from kisumu
most king is worried about bread and
butter issues it's about the economy how
they're going to see their family how
they're going to pay school fees at a
time when the economy is really really
struggling many families say the high
cost of food prices and rising inflation
is making it really really difficult for
them to make ends meet president-elect
william ruto says he's going to turn
around the economy and help low-income
households survive he says he'll do that
by introducing social welfare programs
and subsidies but economists say that is
not going to be easy for him to do this
country is heavily in debt it borrowed a
lot of money from countries such as
china to build infrastructure projects
but that money has to be paid back and
economists say it's kenyan taxpayers who
end up doing that so kenyan's hope that
the economy is going to be turned around
by him right now a lot of things aren't
going well in the country for example
behind me some businesses are closed
partly because of the political
uncertainty but also because for months
many businesses have been struggling so
kenyans are looking to see if he's going
to offer them anything new haru mutasa
for inside story
well let's bring in our guests all
joining us from kenya's capital nairobi
we have dennis and tumbi campaign
secretary for president-elect william
ruto marimo waka ochiwa executive
director of syasa a non-profit that
works on youth political engagement in
kenya and we have bobby mkhungi a
constitutional lawyer and former member
of the committee of experts that wrote
kenya's new constitution a very warm
welcome to you all i'd like to start
with you uh dennis and tombi
you were the campaign secretary for the
now president-elect how are you feeling
with the results and and with the fact
that not all the election commissioners
we're endorsing the results
uh thank you very much and uh greetings
to viewers we are elected uh we are
thankful to god
um that the elections were announced to
the favor
of the well-being of this nation and
that the process
uh was the most integral process that i
have and as a nation we've ever gone
through
i think we have to give it to ibc this
time for uh you know giving us a process
that had
uh almost negligible administrative
flaws fast from the election day the
deployment of kiemsket the voting
process was largely peaceful
and also the process of validation and
verification was one of the most
truthful and open process this country
has ever gone through in fact it will be
established as a case study across the
world
that i don't i don't think there's any
global process that a global electoral
process that has been as open as we have
ever seen and we are thankful to god
that um there is a strong progression in
terms of electoral democracy in this
country so we are very elected and we
are looking forward to
essentially a government that is going
to be inclusive and a government that is
going to um you know uh perform uh you
know um absolute surgery to the issues
that are affecting this nation mr until
we we'll come back to the to the future
in a moment but you didn't answer my
question four election commissioners
cast doubt on the results what's your
reaction to that
our reaction to that is that um i was on
the floor of the bombers i was private
to the dealings
in fact
the vice chair uh who is a part of the
team that is complaining
read the elections of 22 read the
results of 22 constitutions
and
we are surprised that uh
she's part of the team that is
complaining they were involved all
through
and uh you know if there's anybody who
has issues i think they should
you know go through the constitutional
mechanisms to complain i think now they
have the law provides the question
provides seven days um you know towards
the litigation and 14 days towards the
same we are confident that the process
was uh was verifiable and
we we don't see issues from our end
whatsoever and the law is very clear
that it is the the chairman of the
commission uh that is the presidential
returning officer and the one
positionally obligated to then
call the president-elect to being okay
so you're happy to see the process
through um narima
raila odinga obviously isn't happy
should we expect his supporters to
continue protesting and what's the
feeling among
young people in the country how did they
vote
well uh thank you for having me this
time around the turnout was a little bit
low compared to what we're used to at 65
percent
when you look at the overall number that
could vote 22.1 million
39.8 percent were young people and young
people between the age of 18 to 35 in
kenya which was about 8.8 million so
young people already a little bit fewer
from 2017 they were 50
of the voters blocked so there's a big
dip
many of them just decided not to
particularly participate when we look at
this particular election both coalitions
very very strong
garnering half of the country both of
them so yes one side is extremely elated
and excited another is grieving and even
this afternoon he did mention in a press
briefing
that he is going to take their matter to
court so some of his supporters are
excited about that some of them are
feeling drained and frustrated about the
entire process and time will tell they
do have the right to do so if they feel
that the process was not adequate enough
for them
okay bobby mkhangi uh from a legal
perspective with the legal challenge
that looks likely to happen how does it
work what should we expect in the coming
weeks
well um as uh
my co-panelist has just said
uh
honorable rylodinga this afternoon did
mention that um
he and his coalition party azimiyo
emilio
will seek if i may quote him
all constitutional and legal
options and so we are to assume that he
is going to file a petition
in the supreme court uh seeking the
invalidation of uh
uh chairperson uh felicia cathy's
pronouncement yesterday so the
constitution dusted that
after
the declaration
any person so it does not have to be the
contestant it's any kenyan who feels
that they have an issue
with the process and the declaration
they have a period of seven days and
that begins counting from today
and ending next tuesday to present their
case before the supreme court of kenya
and as delhi salia said
the supreme court
will have 14 days
to to to hear to receive
evidence and and and also for
respondents whoever they will be
to file their defenses and at the end of
the day after 14 days there will be a
determination and the determination can
go
two ways only either validate uh the the
pronouncement from the chairperson which
means that the president-elect will be
moving forward
now
towards being sworn in
which will be
after seven days
or
invalidation which
whose only route now will be a fresh
election which must be conducted within
60 days of the supreme court's uh
decision okay bobby mcconkie before we
move on from you you've
explained the process and and and you
know the constitutional basis for this
my question is do people trust the
process do people trust the courts will
they accept whatever the result is
well they don't
have an option but to accept
uh whether they agree with the decision
or not that's a you know their
prerogative and right now
this will be the third time if uh
if if we have petitions uh since the
constitution was promulgated in 2010 um
the first
election uh in 2013 uh there were
petitions uh similarly in 2017
and now if we do have uh one
this will be the third time that kenyans
are being visited with this this this
scenario so at the end of the day uh
there are those will be happy with the
decision that the supreme court will
arrive at and those those will not be
had with it but
as i said earlier
accept it they have to because that's
what the constitution
demands and prescribed agree with that's
a prerogative of each and every kenyan
and you know other people
dennis and tombi uh assuming that the
supreme court validates these results uh
and everything goes through for mr ruto
how does he plan to unite the country i
mean the numbers speak for themselves it
was an almost equal proportion of people
almost not quite who who don't believe
that he's up to the job
i agree um
one of the things that we have to look
at
the
democracy within the
voting electorate
is that it is not equally proportionate
to the entire percentage of the nation
and therefore we have a segment of
people that
essentially
getting the government of the day into
play
but the president sits as the nation as
a symbol of nationality
there are specific instruments and the
chapters and articles in the
constitution
that then ratify him to be the president
over the entire nation and so
one of the opportunities that his
excellency willian samuel ruto has
is to unite the country and his campaign
has largely been about unity you realize
that if you study the thematics of this
campaign
one of the things that
it was not present in kenya's tribalism
and why was that not there because the
unifying factor that he brought on board
was about the social economic
development of the people according to
article 43 of the constitution that
grants kenya's the rights to social and
economic stability
so this time around the various
coalitions were not about regionalism or
it wasn't about
ethnicity negative ethnicity as we've
seen before so already his campaign
theme is uniting the nation because the
nation is under economic peril you know
they're critical questions about
searching inflation
uh there are critical questions about
that tax regime that is extremely
punitive and the joblessness of millions
of young people and millions of kenyans
at the end of the day we have just come
from a pandemic
the exiting um administration has had
critical issues in terms of the quality
and the efficacy of governance so he has
a lot of work to unite the country and
not just unite the country to get the
country to realize his socio-economic
goals and that is what he will do before
the elections were called one of the
things he did was called honorable raila
and they had a chart for about an hour
and they discussed that whoever who wins
uh
will be able to uh
have an inclusive government whoever who
loses should concede and they have
worked with honorable raila before i
mean he's a political player that has
been in the fields uh before in various
positions in government he knows his way
around the political uh infrastructure
or topography and therefore he will be
able to navigate himself and establish
the one kenyan notion under the banner
of economic prosperity which is a
language that comes across there is no
issue
that is specific to a particular tribe
the issues in this country whether than
being socio-economic or health or any
other issues are cuts across the board
okay so from the campaign thing there's
already a united factor and i think that
you will have the responsibility going
forward to unite the country based on
issues and ideals rather than the
concept of tribalism okay narimo ochiwa
if this election has
in fact evolved i guess is the word from
being uh
about
ethnicity or regional issues into these
broader issues that affect all kenyans
are there still chances then this may
escalate to violence because that's
that's been the concern isn't it isn't
it
looking back through history there has
been a concern that things could
escalate into violence
uh looking back through history uh it
was a concern but i believe that the
point of concern happened yesterday most
of the attention was around the
declaration of president and the fact
that that has already happened and
that's why we saw a little bit a little
bit
of chaos i wouldn't call it conflict it
hasn't yet escalated to the extent that
we should be concerned about for many
they were going out to the streets to
celebrate for some they were frustrated
and they did come out on the streets but
they were also some people taking
advantage of the situation like we've
already mentioned the high cost of
living there's no employment
opportunities for young people so
there's a lot of crime that happened
last night but i do believe that now
that we have our way forward the fact
that honorable ray laudinga did have a
pre-statement and he did not agree with
the results and they have decided that
they're going to the courts his
supporters have a way forward and they
are going to wait uh that is one thing
that we have practiced it's taking
issues and petitioning them to the court
and waiting for the judiciary to give us
whatever their opinion on their verdict
is going to be and kenyans are good at
that so i do think that this is one
election we have managed well as a
public and we will continue to wait and
see on the way forward bobby mchangie
correct me if i'm wrong but in 2017 the
presidential vote was nullified uh by
the supreme court citing irregularities
so how is this time different or similar
well um
one thing i have to mention is that
and perhaps you know in agreement with
what dennis did without
uh alia
um in my opinion uh i think the supreme
uh sorry the the the
um iabc
uh the election management body this
time around did uh put effort in
ensuring that it does conduct elections
as was prescribed
upon nullification
of the 2017 presidential elections by
the supreme court of kenya
and that is why we have seen a lot of
infusion of
transparency we have seen a lot of
infusion of
inclusion of
other players we have seen the
appropriate
use of technology
where the failure rate was very very low
if it's the the kim's kids for verifying
and identifying voters um i think it's
less than 250 out of
46 000 plus that did
fail and we've seen the transmission of
results
digitally
and
available to an open
ibc portal as the elections act in kenya
prescribed
uh coming forth and that's why uh this
time around uh you find that uh many
many people why included um you know in
tallying and
and
verifying the results in comparing what
iebc was announcing
and at the end of the day
you look at this and you can see that
iedc has
very much
tried to conduct elections as uh was
ordered by uh the supreme court and this
is in line with the constitution because
in nullifying the elections in 2017 the
uh supreme court of kenya actually uh by
all intents and purposes ordered ibc to
conduct the then repeat election as
prescribed uh by the constitution and i
think this time around despite uh some
irregular uh irregularities which are
expected i mean this is a
human endeavor so
certain irregularities uh will be
expected but at the end of the day in my
assessment and up to now yes we wait to
see
what evidence
those who will go to court will
produce but
to my observation as i was saying this
has been to a minimal marginal
negligible degree
and
i don't see
any uh you know a substantial
reason why uh ibc could be held to fault
uh to the extent that it held
an incredible uh and uh and not free and
fair election okay um
we we uh sort of mentioned earlier about
some of the challenges facing the
president-elect
um talk to me a little bit more about
the state of the economy and
what his plan actually is to address it
thank you very much that is a vital
question and that has been the premise
of this campaign platform
the fact that this country needs a
socio-economic resuscitation
or a resurgence of the same
uh because kenya is faced with a
multiple of economic issues many of them
really
pegged upon what is that we call the
mismanagement within the governor's
sphere
um even before we got to
the pandemic which made things worse
is that
you know there were a raft of
tax
increments and tax issues that came
about that
you know made the cost of living on
essentially the commodities aspect when
you're looking at
a you know aspects of
food items gas
and many other many other things
including transport dreads they really
affected the citizens of this country
and therefore also the question of
joblessness we had about almost about
seven million there about uh young
people or kenyans who
then have no job at all and then also
what it is that happened is that our
economy moved
from almost about 30 percent for more to
almost now about 90 percent informal
that even if you graduate from the
university you have to start perhaps as
being a welder or selling something in
the streets and they're about so this
country has made economic issues also we
are rearing from
very expensive external debts
which is commercially based uh majority
even over of our repayments they're
about we are using that to pay our debt
so they are a raft of issues that
especially are economic based that he
must deal with and that failure to deal
with many of those issues in fact the
political question was was kenya going
to go to sri lanka away or not uh but so
he has to also to deal with very
expensive corruption within a
you know governance speakers and that's
the reason why he was talking about the
conversation and the question of
instituting a quasi-judicial commission
on state culture uh which if you look at
transparency international transparency
national says that the many years that
kenya has done law reforms and what it
is that we call impotent anger there is
nothing much that has come out of the
fight of corruption and therefore the
way to go maybe the south african way in
terms of doing a question judicial
public hearing on state capture there
about so he has faced with a raft of
issues
but the key that he has to to deal with
is the cost of living the inability of
penance to put even
affordable food on the table because
what has happened for example if i give
you just a first example is that we are
unable to
to get
something like our staple food on the
table locally in the country in january
a 50 50 kilogram of a bag of maize was
going for about 2900
today it's going for about 6900 and it's
unavailable locally many of the small
and medium-sized millers are shut down
and as you're well aware the the exiting
president had put in a
a subsidy program to be able to buy
maize internationally and mail locally
which again that one has not worked
because i hear what you're saying
i hear what you're saying about the cost
of living crisis we are coming to the uh
nearing the end of the program so i just
want to throw it over um before we run
out of time to narimo ochiwa
because your uh non-profit works with
youth political engagement in kenya
we've talked about how youth
unemployment is high
we've talked about the cost of living
crisis how hopeful are young people
about the possibility of change about
the future about the political
establishment being able to offer them
hope
many of them uh did not participate in
this election because they do not
believe that a major change is going to
happen frankly a lot of them believe
that a lot of the candidates are very
similar and the same but there has been
a rise of young candidates entering
politics as many of them were kicked out
during the zoning of the political party
primaries but a number of them did sail
through so there is some hope there
where young people are investing in
other young people in leadership but
also these conversations around perhaps
we need to change how we engage young
people zambia in the election last year
had a high majority of young people
participating but it's also because they
had the option of online registration
the iebc is not there yet as much as the
registrar of political parties that has
a platform for young people to register
to join parties online that is where we
can start because when we look at
political party engagement or membership
real true membership young people are
the minority members in our 85 political
parties combined all right we'll have to
leave it there for time uh big thank you
to all of our guests dennis and tsumbi
narimo ochiwa and bobby
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vidal and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]